i got tickets going on sale right now
and
uh they're at theovonne.com tour
and that st louis cincinnati charlotte
durham chattanooga knoxville wilmington
wilkes-barre and some other places
charleston richmond albany buffalo
columbus and minneapolis
today's guest is returning to the
podcast she's a
very entertaining comedian she has a new
tour
that she's embarking out on she's also
the host of the upcoming
mtv movie and tv awards
ladies and gentlemen nikki glazer
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Applause]
yeah it's good over there it's just like
something like
sometimes you have to
[Music]
tell me what it's like i like your shoes
you do thank you i get a lot of
compliments on these they are not real
snake skin but
you shouldn't even wear fake stuff i'm
vegan because if you make it look good
then people are like
i want that you know if you make fake
look good
then you're hurting the animals no i
don't i that's i think that's pretty
that seems crazy but
do you think vegan can you eat snake or
not
no no you can't eat people always forget
that vegan is like
everything like i eat honey if something
honey's in something i'll go okay fine
but a lot of vegans like won't eat honey
because it
like it exploits bees no way i
but bees want us to have it because also
when you think about all the stuff that
bees do to
us and all the what if he's done to us
we're getting revenge all the child do
you know how many of summers of mine
were ruined because bees no they weren't
they were they were ruined because of
your perception of bees
as being like people are so scared of
bees their sting doesn't hurt that bad
you might if you're allergic yes i
understand but like we all
we were so annoyed with bees we killed
them all and now our
like our whole planet is collapsing
because there's no bees
oh dang but what were your run-ins with
bees as a kid let's get your top
three bee incidents well the big one was
always your child
at summer camp they always had bees
there for some reason
you know and so we go there to this
place called uh
bogafilaya park and it was just like
all the kids would come and it was like
a bunch of this ratchet kids and like
we'd all have our lunch box and like our
our our kool-aid would like spill over
on our sandwiches and it was so gross
it was like ymca summer camp you know
yeah and some kids would leave during
the day and just wander off into the
woods and disappear and like
it was just but i remember at certain
areas they just had so many bees they're
like
like i want to say tens of thousands of
these yeah
and uh but you guys were events canceled
because of bees
oh i would say adventure i would say i
would say kickball games ended early
i would say lunches ended early one kid
uh a b went
up his nose and um
and that was horrible and they had to
get this before that i think they had
the epipens or whatever
oh so this kid was allergic too yeah or
i don't know if he's allergic but he was
one of those kids who their skin was
real clear looking you know
yeah yep like one of those kind of
premature baby kind of thing
yeah that trans kid
or lucent kid i don't know what they do
i think they're called loosens
yeah one of those loose dude so they got
yeah yeah but some kids were never the
same i feel like after that after a
strong bee came through oh people were
people are so scared of bees and i
thought it was just a way that girls
initially i was never really scared of
bees i was just like okay if they sing
you it kind of hurts but
i think being scared of bugs is kind of
like a thing girls do to like
get attention and like be like not just
necessarily from boys but just
they're not being seen enough in their
families so they're just like if i
scream really loud about this thing
that's around a lot
then i'll get attention and it's my
thing i'm like girls that are like i
hate
moist like that's a hack one but people
looking for
the word moist right you know when girls
are like oh my god don't say it and
you're just like
you need an identity beyond like these
things that you think are unique but
we all kind of are on board with yeah a
lot of people say those types of things
i mean but we're all searching for an
identity i mean your haircut
is like a part of like that haircut i
remember when you first brought out
i thought it was for a role or something
and now it's you and it's like
and it's such a look that you've
inspired people to adopt it it's now
like a
hot guy haircut but when you first
debuted it
it wasn't really theo i remember you
walking backstage
at some s i think we were at some one of
amy's tapings or something
and you came backstage and i sound
handsome
i laughed at your haircut i thought it
was a joke
i thought you were trying to joke us
really yeah i did i'm being honest with
you
but i thought but i also was like it
looks good you know like the type of way
like a like on halloween people look
still look good
yeah then you kept your halloween
costume on and i was like yeah and then
and now it's still here and that was
probably
six years ago how long has it been five
years ago well i had long hair too when
i was a kid and i just liked i
i never felt i never knew i was supposed
to have long hair as an adult
until i had you know you weren't
supposed to i never knew that i was
supposed to
oh oh you mean like you found your truth
like this is who you are yeah yeah
i just never felt i just like feel more
like a man i feel more like a
courageous man i feel like more like
somebody that would run into a fire to
help somebody
yeah or not run all the way in i would
run close to the fire and you know
people be like oh he's gonna stop i'd
run up the stairs on the porch
okay because fire is so hot people like
in movies they make it look like it's
not that hot dude fire is
so hot it's so what's the worst you've
been burned
like have you gotten like what degree
let me think probably bad burns oh yeah
dude i went whale
or not whale watching but looking for
something once and uh
and i got sunburned so bad dude
go from whale watching to looking for
your keys like
we were looking for the lord honey we
were looking for the lord
you got sun burnt real bad yeah i think
we were doing drugs or something and
they ended up ending up out in the sun
for way
too long you know and my friend kept
dozing off we ended up at this elton
john concert and he was on opioids
and he literally kept dozing off dude
and one time we thought he was
dead but we were so much that we kept la
like nobody would check to see if he was
dead it was kind of like uh
not like freeze tag but some like weird
game you know it was like a kids game
you know
and um so you thought he was dead some
of you were scared by it but mostly
it was just like like that's hilarious
everybody was just laughing it was just
one of those days you're like oh
you know sean's
but i guess yeah i think things like
that bees sunshine
things like that i guess you're
terrified of the sun a lot of it's
dangerous i don't go in
son i've been i've known that aging as a
woman is a bad
thing so i haven't been going in the sun
since i was in high school i used to
always sunbathe
and i used to cover my face and
decolletage with a towel when i was like
15 like oh wow
just to be like i don't want to be
wrinkly when i'm older
i even knew at a young age when you're
supposed to think you're young forever
like
plan ahead and the truth is it's like
you can't really stop it it's just gonna
happen
it's hard i i think yeah i think i'm
starting to realize even just growing up
that it's hard to get it's hard to get
older it's a little tough you know it's
like
it's kind of uh
it's just so it's
it makes me i often realize how much
time i probably wasted
whereas like time used to be this thing
it'd be like sure have some of my time
you know yeah like i've got as much time
you know
who wants some of my time you know you
used to have so much times like you're
running around this big bag of time
and then now it's like ugh you know i
don't have a second to spare
you know and it's like time it's just
right i mean like you watch on any of
those things about
the tech companies that are trying to
create
things that take our time like our time
is the only thing we can't get back
yeah so it's like they really just want
our
our attention and like what what you
give attention to but
i feel like getting older and realizing
oh the things i've wasted my time on
have not really
that kind of being like god i wasted so
much time doesn't help me not waste time
now because i'm not i'm just finding new
ways to waste it but you know what i do
now
like when i find like what's something
you wasted your time on that you can
think about in the past that you have
masturbation probably
listen i also i don't think that's a
waste of time
it's [ __ ] awesome what it's awesome
but you get the hang of it and then it's
kind of like it feels good
you wanted to feel good yeah you needed
it like i feel like uh any time but it's
like am i still
doing it you know it's like when you do
it again you're like uh
where do you want to be right now doing
too much masturbating didn't get you to
where you want to be like you are where
you you know like
no regrets feel like everything i don't
think i'm where i am because i've been
masturbating i think it's
i think i could have probably done other
stuff and probably done it well
when you think how many trades you could
have learned okay so what trade do you
want to know
that you would take some of your
masturbation time like because oh
landscaping
something outdoors you know painting now
is the time for that when your libido
falls
back then you weren't going to go
landscaping if you wanted to jerk off
if i didn't have if i didn't have a
libido i think i would have done a lot
of stuff i wouldn't
someday lose it probably you know and
then that's when you get into like
but not these days no no no
no no these days you get the fake
the men now they get the you get a fake
uh
you know they have all these enhancers
and everything they have all of this
it's like yeah
they're gonna ha you're basically just
gonna have like 80 year old zombies
wandering around
but it doesn't it gets your dick hard
but it doesn't get your like heart hard
so like
guys not heart are like your brain hard
you know so guys will take it to [ __ ]
their wives if their wives
if they want to make them do it but
they're not they're not propelled
by sex with women so therefore
you're not having to like feed this
addiction which is like the porn like
jerking off is really just like a porn
addiction and just like uh feel good i
don't want to feel my feelings feel is
the easiest way
yeah that's just one choice but when you
don't have a libido later on you're just
going to put that obsession into like
woodworking or whatever
or you know canoeing or um
it would have just been nice to have
pictures of myself like in a canoe or
with like a nice statue i'd done or
something when i was younger you know
you
you didn't do any you have no
accomplishments when you're young you
weren't like an eagle scout
or something you seem like you i didn't
know how to like whittle or do a whistle
okay do you if we had to do like a
talent show
and it couldn't be stand up and it
couldn't be podcasting or interviewing
go back to high school talent
let's let's do let's do a talent like
right now theo like if you
if we were in a talent show with a bunch
of comedians and none of us could do
comedy
what would yours be that you have the
best shot of actually being considered
like oh my god he's good at that like
what do you have any secrets
no nick might know even better than me
i'm still stuck on you
one accomplishment you emancipated
yourself when you're 14. i got
emancipated when i was a child so
probably
legal separation from family yeah i
don't know how you're
going to perform that at this talent
show but i think i could do it if we had
like a small black box theater
yeah again it's a performance but yes
you're right
i um that is incredible so maybe i guess
something like that like yeah like i
could probably do some ilian gonzalez
type ship
like you you know like something like
that i could probably do some ilion
gonzalez reenactment wait a second just
let me get this straight you emancipated
yourself from your parents when you were
held
14. that's [ __ ] badass got out there
yeah what can i just ask why
yeah i just didn't like it there it just
wasn't the best fit for me did you know
that it wasn't even a possibility to do
that oh
i don't know i don't really remember i
honestly don't remember what happened i
remember
we met yeah i remember we just you know
do you have siblings
that's how it came down to it yeah i got
a couple siblings are you older
younger we're all we're all in the it's
all a couple years apart
wait what what one i'm number two out of
four at four
so you did you they get out did they
follow suit too nope
they all everybody some people stayed in
some people got out
it was basically almost like that uh
who's that guy that had that church out
in ut
in uh texas or whatever yes yes
it was like warren jeff but it was just
my mom oh [ __ ] man well
uh and i love you mom happy belated
mother's day
she knows that but yeah we just have a
relationship with her now i'm sorry
yeah we got a relationship but it's just
really yeah it's like was your dad
around
no he was not around got it but i think
it was just kind of like
you know when you i think when you're
like i don't know it was more like like
just
i think we were more like roommates and
family kind of in a weird way
well the fact that you were 14 and were
able to do that
i mean is incredible because i think
that so often i mean i
even have a hard time being like
doing saying tough things to family
because they're family or doing
something selfishly because your family
like just accepting that
just because they're your family doesn't
mean you have to put up with whatever
they throw at you
right but then also sometimes i feel
like i was i just like a
weak kid who was just afraid to take the
[ __ ] bruh so funny to frame it that
way because
in no way would anyone hear about a kid
taking the initiative to
maybe you were stupid maybe you were
like mom dad don't get her like a kid
could do that
right to get yeah that was amazing i
didn't have a skateboard so that wasn't
me
to make that happen and to actually
legally do that that's someone who
realized i'm smarter than this and i
know i need to get out and i need to
protect myself it's very
i mean that's very independent at a very
young age yeah i think that's what it
was just independent
yeah and that's like that's what did you
do where did you go what was your first
time i went to stay with friends yeah i
went to stay with friends and then i
would take my backpack to school and i
would find
friends to stay with you know so it was
like kind of like this
i think it was very avant-garde i don't
know what that means were you friends
with everyone in high school
avant-garde is kind of like well it's
not the right use of it but
it gets the word it gets the feel across
so you were just
fly by the sea your pants kind of like
you were homeless
i wasn't homeless i was staying with
friends and then i finally found a
friend who could let me stay full-time
so then i went and stayed over there how
long stayed there for a couple years
and we gotta go to college yeah and we
got into some mild drug issues over
there and so then we went our separate
ways huh were you in heights did you
graduate high school
yeah so you emancipated and stayed in
like this wasn't like i'm gonna go be an
adult now
no no no i was just yeah i just didn't i
think it just wasn't like the best vibe
at my house you know
yeah did you um what was your vibe
growing up
my vibe was like were you like a cheer i
could see you being like a cheerleader
definitely like a kind of uh maybe
do you really see that huh do you really
see that is that sad that i see that
i also see you as more than that but no
i would love to be seen as that but that
is not how
really your arms i feel like are so
straight thank you i could be
well that's just not the right one to do
but like yes like
rah rah rah yes i would be good thank
you
that's when i was on dancing with the
stars i met my partner and he didn't
know that i wasn't a good dancer like i
got
i lost the show i was voted off first
but when i walked in
he you could see he didn't know who i
was we were meeting for the first time
and you could see him be like oh my god
yes like she looks like she can
dance like ballerina kind of oh yeah and
then we did like a quick like he wasn't
even teaching me something he's like
okay let's let's just we did a quick
thing
and i saw him age like seven like his
face dropped
so severely of like he knew he knew our
fate because i just don't have like a
natural talent so
i would never try it out for
cheerleaders because i wasn't like sex
cheerleaders are sexy i wasn't like ever
trying to be sexy aren't they those some
cheerleaders were cute
well there's like a perception of like
anyone i didn't like to dance
i didn't like to i didn't want to do
anything sexual i'm now realizing this
as i say it that's why i
was i didn't have a rhythm already okay
but also it was mainly about like short
skirts and being like
like having your belly out and like
being like boys like me like i didn't
like boys and i
loved boys but i was just so scared of
them and so i would never do anything to
like draw attention to myself in that
way
and what were you scared of that they
were going to be rapers or that they
were going to be like i was going to be
bad at making out or that i was or like
whatever we were doing that i would be
batted and they would tell their friends
and make fun of me
biggest fear because it happens all the
time because i would hear stories of it
constantly every day from my guy friends
so i saw it happening around me
well i feel like being a girl i couldn't
imagine him being a girl when i was
young that would be yeah that would suck
so many i just didn't want the the [ __ ]
that came with hooking up with guys
yeah maybe if i one girl i remember she
blew
my crush oh my god i love this guy so
much and she gave him a [ __ ] and she
threw
up because he gagged her with it it was
it's a normal thing to happen and
sometimes can be kind of hot
yeah some people have small windpipes
yeah she was like high school girl
giving
deep getting deep throated by a guy who
just got oh my god you know
like we had aol at that like he was
getting images that probably inspired
that and then she threw up and then
the story is like what an idiot she is
you know and that's the whole story and
i even perpetuated that like did you
know that she threw up on his dick
because
it was just like to me girls sucking
penises it was just like a betrayal
of to me as a woman like i was just like
i can't believe whoever did it first
ended everybody else's childhood so
those people need to be called out in
every town oh
whether it's ronnie and melissa or
whether it's scotty and jyn
or whoever whoever got the first blow
job and received the first blow job in
your grave i'm not kidding you theo i
ruined everybody else's child i cried
when my best friend since fourth grade
gave a [ __ ] because i thought i go
i've
i've lost her like we don't yeah we'll
never you i just want to eat nerds with
you and go to the sweet factory
and get a bunch of candy and then go in
the photo booth those days are over go
to the gap and like
dress up in funny outfits i don't want
you sucking a penis like what happened
so
those days are over now she's wearing
short shorts and she's hanging out
she's at the gas station she's like
giving hand jobs and now all my friends
are eclipsing me like they're all
make making out even the girl that i go
oh my god she's never
she's going to be the when we went to
high school we predicted who's going to
be the first to sex boyfriend all the
stuff
is over thinking about that yeah we were
like oh my god who's going to be the
first with a boyfriend who's gonna be
the first to
uh get her period uh lose her virginity
all these things and
all the super they all went to me
everyone thought i was like poised for
all of this and i left high school a
virgin who had never had a boyfriend
um and who had never blown anyone
oh and who had only made out when a guy
like had to be kind of like not tricked
into it but they had to be on spring
break when no one else knew
and then um even though he was the most
popular boy in school and he they just
couldn't
he it just happened i went to spring
break my junior year
and i wasn't not i wasn't not attractive
but this this this spring break i really
blossomed it was a good one for me but i
go down to florida and meet my
girlfriends
what part of florida uh fort myers oh
yeah
shady 0-1 called it boy because it was
sb01 and we're
we're cruising down the strip we're in a
we're getting guys cars that are just
like cruising we're like can we go to
town and it's like you're my butterfly
sugar baby we're just like whoa like
spring break but we're dorks like we
we've never a couple of us have kissed
boys did y'all have any tattoos or did
somebody just get one
oh no we weren't 18. we were like 16.
like we bare we didn't drink
we were we weren't that cool but we were
just like thought we were badass
but so we're flirting with boys going
around town meeting guys
nothing's really popping off then my one
of my friends has kind like she's on the
water polo team because she's kind of
like likes to do boys stuff you know
and so she's friends with some of the
cool guys and so she has like a maybe
association with them
and then but we are on the beach in fort
myers and
who rolls up on the beach
the tone look of my high school oh i
thought it was a musician
no it was it was cisco he was shooting
his video
no way i'm going yeah no it was
the most popular boys in my in my grade
who would never even consider
they rolled up on y'all because they
were striking out they weren't [ __ ] down
in fort myers they were killing it in
kirkwood in the halls of kirkwood high
school but here no one gave us they were
just some dorky
like you know midwest boys so they ran
out of options
because it was the best girl i'm telling
anyone listening
plan a spring break where the hot girls
group of girls is going and the guys
aren't going
because they will know you the
familiarity will make them
invite you over and then you'll get to
kiss two of the guy that was my first
kiss was like two of the most popular
guys in school
and then they went back and they
wouldn't tell anyone and i had mono oh
yeah there's always that chick who had
mono dude all the time we had a girl who
had mano for like seven
years we're like somebody just take her
life
can we just sacrifice her please at some
sort like
something else god wants her back yeah
that
was yeah the kissing disease and you got
like really tired and it was
um but yeah i was just i was such a
prude in um high school
and we had a fellow he'd always get
hiccups around gay people too all the
time
that guy's gay no he would just get him
it was like he just
if people was gay he would get hiccups
and then could you scare him out of it
by
no you had to drink water do or have
sugar or something you know do one of
the treats what do you do to get rid of
hiccups because
there there's a way that works the best
yeah what do you do
i just know they're going to go away now
because i'm an adult and i don't really
worry about it as much so when you get
them you just stop thinking about them
then they go away
yeah pretty much or i'll hold my breath
for about five or six seconds you just
hold your breath
it's real easy but when you're younger
it's like it just
you know i there's probably people who
have taken their life that thought they
couldn't get rid of their hiccups and
just
yeah i mean why isn't there a cure that
we all just go this is it like where's
the race for the kids where's you when
yeah yeah that's that should be our
cause that we all settle on
yeah you just hold your breath until we
go away i remember so when i was young
they had this
kid in our school named patrick right
and he got a little bj from this girl
right
back to bj's yeah and so everybody's
fired up people are cheering him on
people are drawn on their notebook like
yes yes yes you know
people are excited so he got one and
everyone's excited he got wonder what
he's excited
okay well what happened was then his uh
the girl's parents found out so
her parents had to go over to his
parents house
her parents called his parents what
and they all had to go over and talk
about it i would love to follow up with
you
today and hear their side of this that
is excruciating
so here was the crazy part uh so he let
me be on the phone he kept the phone off
the hook you know you keep it off and he
just kept it in the living room yeah
so you heard what happened what happened
oh it was the most awkward conversation
ever
um did they talk explicitly there was
like blame yes there was like
hey you know we think it's your fault
it's like nobody's fault it's like
oh my god when did when was your first
[ __ ]
i think it was probably the same girl
actually a couple of weeks after that
honestly honestly really if i had to be
real honest with you yeah
but i got real scared i was at a party
i think i was probably 15. so after the
emancipation
i was at a party yeah things went uphill
you know i was at a party and uh some
girl was
uh it was my girlfriend actually at that
time i think or
she or she i was who i don't know if we
were a girlfriend or an honor but
yeah um oh and it was like behind a tree
but it was like the parents were at the
party and then
the this was your first yeah the mom
came around the tree
yeah yo yeah and i got so scared you
know that's a crazy story why would you
just be remembering this you got caught
getting your first
job and i was like we're just looking
for something you know i just didn't
know what to say what would you say you
know
and then i felt so bad for me i felt bad
for her the jig is up like weird we're
caught
we're busted i'm not gonna use a racial
slur dude i'm just saying that yeah
i'm just saying that i mean i don't know
if it is rob but i'm not even taking him
it's weird saying it but i also don't
feel like i would even be able to
conjure what race that is so i feel like
i'm in the clear
yeah you know what i mean oh you're
totally i don't want to dip you out of
like
talking about race but no i think we're
going to be alright no i think
gypsy is not a thing you should say
dipping someone out of something
very not good my brother used to work
with some gypsies and um
spirit animal oh yeah you know when
girls go oh my god you're my spirit
animal i'm
which that's i get that compliment a lot
yeah it's like
i know that humans are animals but it's
supposed to be an animal right you know
like
but also native americans because that's
like a native american thing and we're
just going like
oh my god like that little koala is my
spirit
like baby teacup poodles are my
spirit animal and these are native
americans are like
that was like founded on the fact that
like the like a great sp
like we believed in that spirit like we
actually thought that our tribe leader
was do you think or red bear or whatever
yeah but they thought that we could
think that man everybody could think
making it like cute and like fun but
that's because if some girl does that
and she's pulling on her hair and stuff
like that and she's never had a job
say it but then that girl needs to get a
job i think she can still
say you don't want a girl to be like my
spirit animal
is actually that's what i want i want
somebody more if you had to us
let's not say spirit animal but what
animal do you look at and you go
oh yeah duh okay but why it's just
because man
you know have you always liked rats are
great i would want to get one as a pet
but they die very soon
well i had to share room one night with
two um not rats it's like the limousine
of rats
uh ferret oh and i had to share a room
one night with two of those
no wait has he said that before i
haven't heard it
oh i'll tell you this story dude said
limousine of rat before
that is so [ __ ] funny why you know
ferrets urinate on each other's backs
that's you you are true you are my
you know that yeah i'm just gonna say
essay i'm not gonna say
you are so funny and i can't let
limousine the limousine of rats
a ferret go if that's the funniest thing
we've said on this episode then we are
not doing well
what are you kidding me you're you're
you're doing great i think you look
great i know i think that is the
funniest thing and i am f
i'm fine saying that's the funniest
thing i've ever been a part of ever
that's so funny dude remember epilepsy
remember how big that was i remember
remember epilepsy was big think about
the things that were big when you were
young
evanescence yeah wake me up inside
can't wake everything she was like save
me but everything was like
i just work at cpk california pizza
kitchen and she would just be like
howling over them
and every girl that worked at cpk could
wake relate up you get off work you're
just smoking in your car
oh my god yes i would smoke cigarettes
all the way home from cck after
memorizing them
there was nothing better than smoking a
cigarette on your way home from work
work whoa that's a good one
now it's finally after work no i you
think
i i really enjoy it i love but it's not
the same like i love smoking a cigarette
and like listening to it like a great
song and just feeling cool
because cigarettes do make you feel cool
vaping doesn't look as cool
it does just because like younger people
do it so i guess younger people are cool
and you're like oh i guess that's cool
but
cigarettes i i i hate them and they
destroy lives and i haven't smoked one i
only had one
in 12 years or something and i put on a
dime and it's very easy to quit but
i do think they're they look cool
cigarettes and they're fun
oh yeah they're a real thing now people
are sucking like this electronic thing
it just has a different vibe
but dude there was nothing better i
remember i get out of work
light that match up i want to have this
fake cigarette
and shoot this like we're like mad men
and just be cursing everybody i worked
with as i laughed just said like nothing
mattered i was like where were you
working that you were leaving
i was bus boy i did mostly bus buying uh
throughout the south mostly throughout
the southeast region okay
uh you don't want to give any chains uh
just like
i worked at a place called bj's pizza
house
and they went out of business they got
there was a uh
there was some i think fraud and also
the
land the owner or somebody got cancer i
think maybe his girlfriend got cancer
but also they had a fight they had a
marriage dispute
um what else uh
well my first [ __ ] was okay damn well
here we go
it i know that everyone's all you do is
talk about sex but really well i did
have a good time
trying to talk to women about work and
they just want to tell you i don't want
to hear about
the first [ __ ] i wanted you to say
like a funny place you worked i didn't
hear to hear like the whole backstory of
your
sorry no i was intrigued even though i
literally don't remember one detail from
it but um
did you work in an ice cream place now
that i could see what bess can rob
no okay first of all i was not a
cheerleader dude i would have bought a
thousand
scoops i would have let you scoop it
with your hands yeah that's so
nice i really appreciate that like i
remember
taste some of it off your back that's
what i would have said you know sorry
that's out of line i'm sorry
so nice i want to thank you i like
um when people uh allude to wanting to
have sex with me i think it's like very
nice
when it's done in a way that you're just
like when they're just like jokingly
saying it like that means
a lot hearing that from you because i
obviously that's like the struggle
of my life i think is like wanting to be
[ __ ]
and also wanting to be funny and fun and
be in and then people being like
god she's trying too hard to look
[ __ ] it's just like i
can't i dr i i didn't discover that i
was [ __ ] until very late in life
and i also am not married so who gives a
[ __ ] and whatever but what i was gonna
say about that is like also
i i even hate being like my first blood
job because people are gonna write in
comments like
all she does is talk about sex she's
just trying to shoe horn a sex story but
this i
actually think it's interesting but what
i was gonna say what did you say you i
worked at an ice cream store and i
worked it up
a pizza place and i worked at a nail sal
or um
my first job was at like a hair salon as
like the
receptionist and i did this job and
my no well yes but i like was taking
appointments and we used to write them
and i cried so much on the job
one day my tears splashed down and like
totally ruined a whole appointment and
like you couldn't read any of it and my
boss had to comfort me and i
i just left and never came back and she
was calling my house trying to pay me
and i was just like
i can't be seen there again like i was
just i would tempt you here in l.a
when i was struggling i was nannying
most the time because it's just like
they trust you if you're like a woman
who smiles yeah like they don't think
you'll like hurt their kids
it's all about the jpeg when it comes to
nanny and i feel like i mean it's all
about like the pit the picture you know
when you see those all pair websites
yeah oh yeah and like you want someone
who has like
you know references and stuff but i i
was babysitting like with a service that
would just dispatch you and it's so
easy and uh i babysat for judd apatow
oh really a bit that was really cool and
just like gave me
like a peak yeah it was like 25 bucks an
hour
all working better rich but i was doing
like i was temping did you ever temp
did you ever do uh girl what's that
thing
sugar girls or whatever what's that
sugar baby sugar baby
yeah yo i don't know who you think i am
sorry i
don't i cannot have sex with someone i
like like
let alone i don't know very weird about
sex
i know i'm fascinated by your stuff with
it as well because i feel like
i look at sugar babies or like only
girls and like
thoughts and girls that are just like
porn stars i like love them all
and i don't um know
like i but i'm still weird about putting
that kind of stuff out there
yeah oh i remember first yeah when i
even got that first [ __ ] i
even remembered asking my buddy to go
with me because i was nervous you know
yeah i mean i guess guys are nervous too
i mean i would assume you guys are
more driven but girls are like i've got
to get this out of the way i just
i didn't give a bloat until i was a
junior in college and all my friends
i was like they were all having sex
relationships i was just like i haven't
even had sex i gotta blow someone so i
was just like
who was it it was a comedian that that's
the interesting part
is i can't say who it was but it was a
it was see i
i was such a person was he tall or short
medium hmm i bet i know it is i'll tell
you i'll tell you who it is off air but
i can't say it on air i don't want to
know off air
really yeah okay well good i'll tell you
whatever you want to know
because i would trust you but i but i
respect that you don't care
um yeah i don't like knowing some of
that kind of stuff you know
i agree i am actually i like more
mystery
well i like to be able to imagine you
blowing a couple of different people
that i have like i mean my roster isn't
crazy
of people you know but like but that's
the thing everyone's gonna be like she's
such a [ __ ] i literally
i don't think you're a [ __ ] you're also
an adult it's not like you're a child
who's [ __ ] who's like
sneaking into people's houses and
[ __ ] you are a regular adult and you
can have sex
i know but if i were having a lot of sex
i would talk about it it seems like i do
because i talk about sex a lot but i
don't like i haven't had sex in two
years and like what yeah oh we're gonna
get right into that here's a woman right
here that has a question she's obviously
she's not doing well either what's up
oh she australian we can't hear her
she's so cute what you can't even hear
her and you know you think she's
australian what makes you think that
i just get an aussie vibe from her
i can only do one um that's your girl
kevi over here in
uh raf lakenheath england that's royal
air force base
oh yeah i've been there my question for
nikki is
how and i'm sure you'll probably get
five variations of the same question but
it's about coming up as a female comic
um so what i've always noticed is a lot
of female comics will start out like
their first like
big hit gig is like a lot of sexual
based humor
um and then as
the you know their gigs continue it's
like a play off of the same
gig and what what pressures do you feel
i guess it's like a female comic of like
if your humor is not sexual based like
do people think you're not funny anymore
or like what is that trend about i'm
curious obviously not a comic but
it's something i've noticed you know
with female comics and it doesn't seem
like there's a lot of them
but when there are always always sexual
based yeah
just curious does it feel like that as a
future thank you thank you
that's a great question gang gang and i
appreciate your service over there too i
actually did a show at raf lake and
heath one time
it's a great backhanded question so what
she was referencing is
what a lot of people say is like all
they talk about is sex and it's true
because i mean there's this documentary
called hysterical about female comics
and it's the last thing i'm sure
a lot of people want to watch and i'm in
it
and i did not expect this to be so
[ __ ] good and moving like i learned
i watched it and cried at my own story
like i don't cry and i was like
i saw myself as like oh my god you're
such a scared little girl who doesn't
understand her worth and then i watched
all these
female comics that i'm friends with in
this documentary it's so well done theo
you will actually really like it
and um it's one of i love documentaries
it's really well done and i would not
i'm in a lot of [ __ ] is it a real
documentary that's on we can see it
somewhere now well i'm
uh yeah it's called hysterical and it's
uh fx okay and on hulu
but honestly this is not i if i wasn't
in it i'd be promoting it if everyone
had told to watch it
who you would think would be like not
into that they [ __ ]
people have overheard me listening to it
but anyway i watched all my friends on
there being like
what drove them to stand up judy gold
rachel feinstein
uh sherry shepherd margaret show uh
who else bonnie mcfarlane marina
franklin fortune theme sir
it's lazy at least yeah yeah
she's in it i love her but we all and
then the girl that stood up to um
harvey weinstein harvey once was at a
[ __ ] open mic that or the show this
girl was doing and she called
him out it was so brave it's it's
[ __ ] good but my point is
female comics talk about sex at least
it's presented in that documentary
because we were like
silenced about our bodies and like
controlled about for so long that when
you talk you want to talk about
like what you've been told you can't
talk about but for me when it comes to
sex
i i've done fallon like
stand up on fallon four or five times at
this point i can do clean material i
don't have to talk about sex i don't
talk about sex in any of that
that's and i've done i've done tons of
like
squeaky things and people go all she
she's filthy
the thing is i talk about sex because i
like it i'm not trying to talk about sex
with you today because
i am like trying to be like sexual or
because
i don't really i don't think i'm funny
about anything else it's interesting and
no one's talking about it
people still think oh everything's been
talked about it's like no it hasn't
i'm still encountering things that i'm
like i need someone to process this with
me and for me
that is saying it on stage and having
people laugh and go
or have girls go oh my god that happens
to me too i needed to hear that and like
empowering girls i just really want to
do with stand up talk about sex because
i want men to know
how we're feeling and i want to
understand how men are feeling so i want
to express what i think men are feeling
and hear if that's right or not right
and like and be
and make people feel better about it
because i'm just the reason i talk about
sex is because i'm so [ __ ] scared of
sex and like
so also want it but also don't want it
and it's like the most interesting thing
well yeah i mean sex is an interesting
thing it's really like a it's like i
mean it's how we get here also it's like
you don't even exist if somebody doesn't
have sex you know so
that's what yeah the fact that it has so
much magic in it i would be a sex
therapist if i wasn't a comedian if i
didn't have like talent and
wanted to perform i would still work in
the sex field do you think that women
don't get broad enough with their topics
though
no i think talk about whatever the [ __ ]
you want you know like i
anything i do now that's what we're
talking about like hobbies and stuff and
feeling you waste time
when i do something now that feels like
if i masturbate now let's say or do
something that i'm like
i'm trying to think of another or get a
massage like i'm getting a foot massage
after this one really i maybe should
work on some stuff i have do
yeah but it's like those things is not a
waste like i want it
or smoking weed when i probably
shouldn't being like
instead of being like you're smoking
weed this is so bad i'm just like
listen i have a life where i choose what
i get to what
to do and so if i'm doing it i must want
to do it it must be serving me in some
way so just
cut the guilt right and just enjoy it so
that i have that approach now with sex
stuff like
i i will talk about whatever fascinates
me but
sex still fascinates me until it doesn't
when my libido drops when i'm doing
stand-up when i'm 60 i probably won't be
talking about [ __ ]
right well we can always check then you
know
um yeah i think it's tough sometimes i
don't like talking about it because it
just seems kind of vulgar to me
sometimes
yeah that's like so i like thinking
about it sometimes you know
but i don't like really i guess
sometimes i don't like talking about it
but i'm also like
the vulgarity that makes you go but then
that makes you feel shame about right
you're right
it breeds shame you're right like i'm
i'm getting into talking about
molestation
on stage now like i want to do like a
[ __ ] molestation chunk i have not
been molested so as someone who hasn't
been molested
oh you gotta get out there i gotta get
well i'm going to therapy to find it
because i feel like i have
i'm so fascinated by molestation and
what it does to people and and
how much it's happening that we don't
know about and how much it affects so
many of my friends that have
opened up to me so many people were
molested everyone
is jesus why don't we just admit that
everybody's molesting everyone
it wasn't your fault there's nothing you
did if you enjoyed it it wasn't your
fault
if you went along with it it wasn't your
fault you were a kid you
forgive yourself it doesn't mean you're
gay even if you enjoyed it and you were
with a man and now you're in a
relationship
forgive yourself talk to someone about
it i don't understand what that's like
do you ever wish that you were molested
you feel like i i have a joke about it
like being like it would explain
so much if i was able to go oh it's that
because my uncle
and that one time and my mom ignored it
but i wasn't
i was i mean i was assaulted for my
first kiss but in the scheme of things
it was very very minor
and but it scarred me to be scared of
men and feel like they could just jump
on me and i can't get them off of me and
then they'll hate me
today's episode is brought to you by
liquid death
mountain water murder your thirst
is there something interfering with your
happiness in your life do you sometimes
think about a smiley face and then you
you can't even
finish drawing it because you just are
not happy
well better help will assess your needs
and match you with your own licensed
professional therapist
better help now you think man i can't
get help i can't get help
man nobody wants to help me that's crazy
buddy
you can start communicating in under 48
hours with a therapist
that's right from right now it's not a
crisis line it's not self-help
it's professional counseling done
securely
online so if you you know you don't want
to go to your town therapist or you
don't want to go
maybe your wife is the therapist in your
town and you don't want to go because
she's going to know that you got a
problem with her
so that's scary better help want you to
start living
a happier life today i've used better
health
i support what they do you can go to
betterhelp.com
theo that's b e t t e r h e
l dot com slash t-h-e-o
and join the over one million people who
have taken advantage of their mental
health
with the help of an experienced
professional this podcast is sponsored
by better help
and this past weekend listeners get 10
percent off their first month at
betterhelp.com
theo francais
for most of us learning a second
language is hard
something you don't want to do you don't
even want to meet anybody that has a
different language in them
you know some you meet somebody and they
got a little you know they got a little
hugo in them or a little uh
they're speaking a little bit of nova
scotian you can't handle it
well babel is the number one selling
language learning app it's an
addictively fun and easy way to learn a
new language
whether you're planning on traveling
abroad or just want to connect deeper
with
family or former family even step family
babel teaches bite-sized language
lessons that you'll actually use in the
real world
15-minute lessons make it a perfect way
to learn a new language on the go
babble you can choose from 14 different
languages including spanish french
italian
and german right now when you purchase a
three month babel subscription
you get an additional three months for
free that's six months
for the price of three just go to
babbel.com
and use promo code t-h-e-o that's
b-a-b-b-e-l-dot-com
code theo for an extra three months free
babble language for life
what do you think about what was the
thing i was looking at the other
day um are you dating are you dating men
now are you me
being able to meet men here's a guy that
has a question right here this guy right
here is in his car
what up theo gang gang who's the player
nicki so i've been with my girl for
about four years now and i love her to
death
um however i feel like the sex has
gotten a little
predictable in terms of like i know
what's gonna happen how long it's gonna
take who's gonna go where
kind of things like that and i was
wondering
what i can do to maybe spice things up
um without without really having to
ask her what she wants me to do to spice
things up like i kind of want to
surprise her
i want to be like oh i want this this is
new and i like it
so what is some advice what are some
some tricks i can do
to spice to spice things up in my girls
always trying to be a sex guy he's not
excited to answer this
he's trying to be a real sex man what
you got for him all right so
some things that i don't think are for
every woman but that a lot of men don't
know are most women
and you can kind of test these out and
like i'm not an expert in any way and
i've never
thought about answering this but i'm
just going to share some things that i
i like yeah that i think other women
would like okay and it's um
being uh definitely a light choking
can't
ever hurt somewhat like start very like
this if she likes that then she can tell
you to go harder but doing that out of
the blue and just
even a light one still feels a little
bit like what just putting
that you can't go wrong and if even if
she's like no no no
that's fine you didn't do anything you
just put you like you tried a little
something that's fine
no harm no foul um her up
tie us up we like it this is gonna get
girl
everybody i know in a way no no don't
just do
this without like just yeah and make
sure it's indoors also
you and you can start all of this by
saying if at any point you don't want to
do any of this i will stop
starting with that cat's cradle thing
you know what i'm saying don't do like
don't go vote not yeah yeah go like easy
just
you can get stuff on um like all these
websites have like
easy straps to put under the bed that
you can hide before you're even [ __ ]
on the bed when you get on the bed
go just like take her arm kind of go
hold on a second and then she'll be like
wait what
and then put one hand in the thing yeah
then if she's into it like what are you
doing
do the other one then do the then do the
legs then
if she's wearing a pair of underwear
that are easier easily replaceable
like uh put on us put a sleep mask on
her blind folder this is the next thing
these are all consenting obviously
for consent then there's like a writer's
room
try to get her underwear off but you
can't because their legs are down there
and then
take a scissors and [ __ ] cut them off
all right and just be like i don't even
respect your underwear that is hot but
make sure they're not a pair like
hanky-panky that are like 18 bucks a pop
make sure these are some like
you know like just one even actually if
they were
my good pair i would even respect it
more i'd be like this [ __ ] guy
doesn't give a [ __ ] about my nice you're
gonna and then he would like pay me for
them later or whatever
that's hot and then here's the other
thing get her venmo this guy can do with
his girlfriend in four years he knows
her well enough to be able to try all of
this don't do this on like a first date
but then i would say treat her
see if she likes to be uh [ __ ] see if
you
maybe you can like see whatever
you want to know i want to know what
he's into whatever he's into
she's gonna like she girls just want
their
girls just want to feel like a guy's
like and y'all take a bath first too
though
i think that's important yeah get her in
the bath set it up so
or take your own baths i think this ever
cleanliness is always good but he's
asking how to spice it up i feel like
he's not saying that he said it got
monotonous not like musty yeah that's
not his problem
is the back but yeah we'll start who's
not taking a bath
to i like a good shower no matter what
yeah if i'm having sex or watching tv
once you get a relationship then you go
babe this is at your own
swim at your own risk because you i'm
telling you right now it's not good like
morning breath sometimes you're like
it's bad and they don't care that's kind
of hot too
but here's here's a good one good girl
okay this is when you push her to do
things
that might be a little too hoarse beyond
her comfort zone and like she's
like if a girl is sucking your dick and
you grab her hair a little aggressively
and you say good girl sorry i'm not
trying to turn anyone on
it's really it really is good girls love
hearing good girl
and then the final one is uh
tell us we can't come try to make us
come and then say don't you [ __ ] don't
you dare come
like david blaine kind of thing don't do
it and be like and and be like if you
come i'm gonna be really upset with you
like just you don't need to be like i'm
gonna
punch you but like or like i'm gonna
you're not getting you're gonna get the
whip
for you maybe or something yeah it or so
i'm just gonna be really disappointed in
you and she's gonna be like what's the
[ __ ] go but i'm gonna try to make you
come but you're not allowed to come and
like try to if you have that power
dynamic and then when you tell her to
come i swear to god it will be really
really good and no guys know that one
and that one
is a that one's real good that one's a
lifesaver yeah
and to answer wait what were you asking
before
just to spice it up no he had a question
for me before
i think he may just get a card or
something i
yeah you're right he's talking about sex
and these are simple things these aren't
even like
uh bring lube into blow jobs lube makes
things so like
sexy and wet and like pornographic that
you like girls stop
just trying to exist on your own wetness
like just bring in lube
yeah and then bri and then i literally
got outside
toys okay that guy needs hold on this
guy's just
who even knows but i'm giving a grab bag
for your listeners because so many
people are in stagnant sex relationships
bringing a toy into bed is so hot
because
i will tell you don't be threatened by
it because when a guy brings a toy in
i go like i was telling my friend the
other one i was hooking up and this guy
was like that's all i know
yeah bring bring your legos
when this guy was going down on me and
it was just not what i wanted it wasn't
gonna work out
you know but he was doing other thing he
was doing hand stuff that i was like now
that's good but the other stuff is just
a distraction and i can't get there and
then i was like can i just
use my vibrator and he was like sure and
it was such a much better orgasm that i
could have done alone with a vibrator so
i did need him
and it was much better than i could have
done alone with him without like because
we weren't i was not having sex with him
so i was like
but you know what i'm saying men
shouldn't be threatened by toys are you
threatened by them if a girl is like
i don't think i am i'm i just know if
you are
i don't know i don't know i don't know
jesus christ i have no idea anymore
uh what i'm trying to say is uh i think
i think it's like what theo huh what oh
dang i uh i'm just saying that
yeah the guy's having a good the guy's
having a tough time and now you'll be
able to help him out i think that that's
good i think the guy can now have sex
with his wife
i think you're making my advice seem
like too much but i think it was
[ __ ] spot on and i think your
listeners are a lot of men need it
they're gonna need
a lot of men needed a lot of girls need
this this is for the ladies too like
we gotta stop pretending like we all
know what we're doing we don't
and we gotta i get afraid to talk about
stuff that i like that's one of my
things you know i'll get
afraid to talk about it i'll get afraid
to bring stuff up okay so what is
something you can you admit something
that you like here that
maybe women wouldn't know that men like
that are is one of these things that i'm
kind of
sharing with you that you're like oh i
didn't even know to think to do that is
there something in bed that a girl's
done it before and you're like
that's a good one um i just like kind of
like
sneaky stuff like if i i like more of
like a uh
i don't like somebody who's all like
fast and like it feels like they're
trying to like
brazilian jiu jitsu me i like more some
of them like a little bit more of a
uh making love no i don't need like
uh you want a counting crow's song
playing in the background like that
no but i don't mind things sometimes a
little bit more like sometimes you get
somebody in there it's just like they're
so just like
just like yes you got to be on the same
energy level like sometimes it is like
but some like yeah too fast
is like i learned about [ __ ] which i
didn't know from my guy friends is that
a lot of girls start at like a 10.
yeah you start sucking a dick and you're
like i'm giving it my all and it's like
start at a two
don't give them what you got go to a
four keep it at four go
back down to two seven through ten seven
save seven through ten for the future
just save it for the end like i always
went in really aggressive like my first
[ __ ] was
terrible my second third foot like i was
so bad for so long and i probably am not
that good but
what really is good i think about a
[ __ ] is you just have to enjoy it so
now i'm just like i try to just go like
what do i want to do because if the guy
thinks i'm having fun he's going to
think that he's like
he's going to whatever man what if a man
if you're giving a
oral and it's too fast if a man tells
you that is that better
too fast too fast too fast yes that's it
oh my god that's what that's
good a girl will look at you like she
doesn't want to go slower like she's in
a hurry
no no well if someone can't understand
that
it feels better if you go slower and
they're offended by that
that's not someone you should be with
okay and if you're scared to communicate
and i've been like that theo i've i had
a
a guy once going down on me and i was
just like
that's not that's not and i was just
like if you do this like right here i
like had the solution you know i was
like oh my god
you know it's like a massage you're like
up an inch or whatever
and i was like oh my god and he just
goes i got it like he kind of like
like i was trying to figure out the
directions people don't want to yeah
sometimes they want to just figure it
out
navigation like i got it you know like i
was like it's my [ __ ]
i actually got it like i know how to
operate this thing
but then part of this some of that all
takes away the magic i get it but no
it's just like
no it won't because he starts doing
something to the spot i just pointed out
that i can't do myself and that i don't
even know if he's gonna be able to but
let's just see
and then i come a lot like that will be
magical girls don't care if it's like
you know what he made me come but the
coolest thing is he found it without me
telling like girls don't talk like that
just we're fine if you just do what we
tell you to do and do it well it's like
awesome yeah you're right so ask
and tell girls because girls need to
learn i feel like
i didn't learn how to do stuff until i
was in relationships where it was like
we could actually have some real
conversations about what is good and
what's bad and it's like
why make it a guessing game if you know
what you like a lot of times is i didn't
start masturbating till so long
that i didn't and i didn't hook up with
anyone for so long that when every
all these magazines are saying like
communicate with your man what do you
like i was like
i'm 32 and i don't know what i like i
don't even know what to tell a guy
like what do you want me to do on there
i'm like just
like i used to want a guy to just rub
his face in it so he hit something like
i don't know the spot
but now i know a better idea think about
the uh different quarantine purchases
you made
maybe you bought a bunch of uh fresh
squid ink bath bombs
or maybe you bought a uh a lean to or
something or a native american home
well one of your biggest purchases of
the year
usually is insurance and america's
americans overspend on car and home
insurance by billions each year
yep billions that's where the zebra can
help you the zebra
it's the nation's leading insurance
comparison site for car and home
insurance
in minutes you can compare policies from
every major provider
for free all in one marketplace
after a few quick questions the zebra
pairs people with the right insurance
company
for them make insurance your smartest
purchase yet visit the zebra.com
theo you can support this past weekend
by visiting the
zebra.com slash t-h-e-o
wouldn't it be great if there was a a
little manuel or a phantom
that helped you be better helped you
focus
and sleep and act well there is
and if you have 10 minutes headspace can
change your life
headspace it's a daily
dose of mindfulness in the form of
guided
meditations in an easy to use app
it is one of the only meditation apps
advancing the field of mindfulness
and meditation through clinically
validated research
i've used headspace i enjoy it i enjoy
meditation i enjoy
creating space inside of me between me
and the way that i behave headspace is
backed by 25 published studies on its
benefits
six hundred thousand five star reviews
and over sixty million downloads
you deserve to feel happier and
headspace is meditation made simple
go to headspace dot com slash
theo and support the podcast that's
headspace.com
t-h-e-o for a free one-month trial with
access to headspace's full library
of meditations for every situation
headspace.com
theo well this guy's beautiful honestly
oh my god
i'm gonna say that wow what up nikki hi
here by the pool
i'm a 22 year old guy you know on the
hunt for that uh
that kitty i'm always looking for
different ways to
approach a girl at a bar so nikki the
question's for you
what is the sexiest ways a man can
approach a woman at a bar
gang gang gang brother there you go i
mean that energy
like watch your video before you
approach a woman at a bar
and mimic whatever it was that you were
putting in out in that
because that's a sexy guy and like the
way i was just
mesmerized by that it's just like very
like hey
i know who i am hey and that you know
that guy i used to work here
i've never been hit on it like in public
but some things that i would like to
hear is like
i'm sorry you're uh really stunning and
seem
great and uh oh it's not like something
i would say it sounds like
be honest how about honesty like you're
the hottest girl in this bar and i know
that's a line but like if it's true
[ __ ] we want to know what about like
this hey you seem like uh
hey i just honestly i had to come over
and say hey to you
love it i love it and she'll be like hi
and then you can just say um i don't
even i didn't even have a plan for this
but what i like
one thing that i like that my friend
used to do was uh
he would give his email to a girl like
he'd see a girl park
and like on a bench and be like here uh
i think you're really cute i'd love to
take you out here's my email
so let me know if you want to go out and
it's email so it's not as
threatening and if i don't hear from you
i'll convince myself you lost that but i
hope i do
and then
he didn't give me his number so it's
like kind of like okay i need to like
prove this guy worthy of getting
his number so he kind of negs you in a
way with just the email right
and then he also makes it so like either
way he's gonna be fine you're like well
then
that was hot and confident and just what
that was confidence just exude that
and don't wear a shirt and and lose one
of those necklaces
a lot of places you can't even get into
without a shirt though
that's true that's true um okay just a
little deep v just kidding do never dv
never
oh no no no no no yeah i don't have any
of those anymore
um after this conversation i don't uh
what else is going on so how are you
meeting are you meeting people now if
you're not dating
um i i thought you were dating your
opener you guys don't date
andrew yeah andrew cullen andrew cullen
is my
roommate he's my best friend he's my
opener he was my i met him as my dog
walker he's a hilarious comedian
we have a podcast together hold on we
have a podcast together
called the nikki glazer podcast it's
monday through thursday it's like a day
it's like a morning radio show every day
so i would love if people would
subscribe to that he's [ __ ] hilarious
i thought you guys knew each other i
thought you were good friends
um like because he's met before he loves
you i love you we share your
very funny man and we just we just think
the world of you but it's it's
uh so i was like you got to come with me
to oh that's sweet
so he's in another room but um no we
have never
that we don't have that it's like we're
uh like best friends
and it's just platonic and people are
like how could that be and
i don't know it's just like i think it
can be boundaries
yeah and it's great i live i live in st
louis with him i convinced him to move
from new york to st louis
because i didn't want to go back to new
york or la because i could get a [ __ ]
amazing place in st louis it's by my
parents i was there for the whole
pandemic
and i was starting a podcast and i knew
i needed a co-host and i was like i also
want
i'm lonely i want a roommate i don't
have a boyfriend that's awesome i don't
have my friends all are married
so andrew will you move here we got a
[ __ ] penthouse like apartment in st
louis for [ __ ] cheap
we're living the life we're doing our
podcast at home we wake up and we just
meet
he's got a a girlfriend i'm trying to
like
date guys my ex-boyfriend's back in town
where are you meeting these men though
and i love hearing i um i recently fell
in love
uh for like the in a deep deep way for
the first time in my life and i'm like
oh my god
yeah it's crazy and it's already over
but it was awesome and i met that person
in person like on a on a job
and it was just like uh it was it only
lasted like
three weeks yeah wow in three weeks so
it was like mad love like it was like
this fast furious kind of thing yeah it
was a special thing but it was also like
people can't believe how i'm not like
and it only ended
four weeks ago oh my god and i am and i
thought i was i told this person i
wanted to be with them forever like or
not that i wanted to but like you're one
of many men i could probably see myself
you all share a bed at night sometimes
yeah oh my god yeah but i didn't have
sex with them because i don't have sex
with people until they're my
uh tell me they're my like boyfriend you
know like not boyfriend but like just
they're committed to me and like
want to be with me and so we didn't
never it didn't end up being that
because we wanted different things but
i um but it was so nice to fall in love
and like theo i don't know that
have you ever been in love it's scary
yeah i've been in love man when i was
young
no man like hot like love where you're
like
i'm ready to like be with this person
forever where you're like i'm right like
i think i might like like them no matter
what kind of love
like what do you mean like no matter
what like there's a fire or anything
like i've been in love before with guys
and felt like i was i was like literally
probably in love with dave matthews in
high school like the feelings i felt for
him were so intense that
they really yeah until he opened his
bust like
the urinal of their bus up over that
bridge remember that really kinky [ __ ]
and it hit all those people on that
bridge
i love when he's scatting oh wait no
that's the joke yeah
i think he was opening up for jim norton
jim norton yeah that was
that was a bad moment in the um dave
matthews they picked
you know how they do the river green for
st patrick's day in chicago
he was celebrating um
another holiday that associated i
couldn't think of one i didn't even want
to try do you know what i'm saying
it's just like i don't know um that
would have been a fun joke to make
uh do you think sometimes that
but as we get older our brains get a
little less acute for making jokes if
you started to notice that no there was
the jokes were there i just couldn't
make them because it seemed like it
might be racist or something
oh like if they painted it green for
sure it's brown
for what's a [ __ ] holiday i don't know i
just go to like
brown what's like the most crazy thing
to say about the color brown as my joke
brain and then i go
like racial jokes and then i can't make
any of those so i just go ah
i'll just stare at the own set and laugh
and but
you're right i feel like as i get older
yeah we're getting
slowly like more stupid sometimes i
wonder if my brain gets a little less
acute sometimes
you're you're busting out limousine of
rats
you're just fine like you i watch your
[ __ ] sometimes and i go
it's showing you to someone i'm showing
you to the person i was in love with
actually and i was like he is the
funniest
and i he just goes it's like his
brain works it's like i go it's just
he's just so
you're well known as someone who is just
like justin nick and i were actually
talking about you it wasn't just like
but we were talking about you the other
night and just saying like
how like you're
you're so that your talent is so unique
and like you've always been that way but
it's just like
it's just so cool to see you just like
really refine it and i
i just love watching you and you're so
funny but i don't think you're you will
get more demented this you're peaking
but it's downhill from here because you
know like well
gary shandling did you watch that thing
the judd apatow
uh documentary the three-parter it's so
good but you see this guy that is
a genius kind of start to lose his mind
what happened to him
you know he was starting to get paranoid
about things like who knows what it was
i forget
what happened i think his health was
deteriorating and so his brain
as a result of those things i forget
that it could have been a specific thing
that was leading to this
but he's you know there's a scene of him
on conan later on in his life before his
death
where he's just not sharp and it's like
talking
you feel like you're watching your uncle
being interviewed like that has good
jokes but like
the timing's off and it's like this it's
sad to see
and i know it goes like if i smoke too
much pot my
my my jokes don't get worse but my
memory for what the [ __ ] i'm talking
about gets worse so it gets more like
disjointed
so that's i i i definitely feel
deteriorating from just like
not sleeping from do you feel that way
oh i think sometimes yeah i just did a
cat i just went through a ketamine
therapy too i just did academic therapy
for like two weeks yeah
oh my god oh wait when did you breathe a
little
i felt a little slow even in this
conversation i felt a little
theo i wish i would have known that wait
what can you just quickly tell me
what led you to do that and what it was
yeah what led me to do it i met this
lady and she had done it
and so i'm asking like why do you need
ketamine therapy
oh because i was having so much pain i
was
literally having so much physical pain
from stress
that i was like i have to try something
different so i just wanted to try
something new you know
um and so ketamine for strength
for physical pain because it they know
it's mental well because i feel like
it's definitely psychosomatic pain like
it it comes literally from
stress from like things from thoughts
and like stressful moments that it
happens
you read the back pain book sarno it's
all about that
like i will read it sometime but but i'm
just saying i probably won't read it
no you won't but let me just say it's a
book that has healed
so many my back pain included you read
it and you learn that i don't have any
back pain
but but you know whatever you were
trying to treat the fact that you were
able to acknowledge like this is stress
and i need to treat the stress
not the physical element people are
doing back surgeries and it's all
because it's
their subconscious mind is like
rerouting pain that they don't want to
feel up here to the weakest parts of
their skeleton so
your bulging disc is not supposed to
hurt as bad as it does it is there
but you don't need surgery on it you
need to just acknowledge that it's
stress you don't even need to fix the
stress you just acknowledge that it is
and it will
it will go away but then you slowly
treat it but
ketamine therapy is your pain gone now
well a couple things happen
i mean i feel like it has been going
away i also quit caffeine about two and
a half weeks ago
okay theo trying both those things right
i am totally obsessed with
uh caffeine addiction because i am
addicted to it and i know you asked
about my zevias if they were caffeine so
i
i did note that early on caffeine
addiction
is from my uh i tried to quit caffeine
for 20 minutes and was like felt like i
had covered because of the symptoms
of like in the morning like the
depression just malaise
with lethargy
i think it's lethargy but lethargy too
if you want to say it that way
um which is wrong but it's fine um
but you did you experience that did you
experience like
how did you do it i have been tired i
think i think i've been
tired from not some of the caffeine but
also i feel i definitely feel like some
of the
the the acute pain from the stress going
away
so that feels pretty good and then the
ketamine thing some of it was cool like
some of it got a little scary i was kind
of glad when it was over i was like
how does it go it's just like you go
they hook you up to an iv you're in
there with a therapist and so you just
start talking about stuff
and then you like your brain kind of
goes through like these warp zones and
stuff
and you literally i mean it got way i
mean
i remember at one point i thought it was
a cryptocurrency like it you get
you go pretty deep it you might be a
little bit slower
than you normally are but you didn't
affect your i love
that i'm clearly seeing that whatever
you did did not affect how funny you are
and the way your brain works because i
think so many people are scared
if they treat this stuff they won't be
as funny well i just wanted to try it
like i feel like i'm healthy enough to
try it i'm healthy enough to have an
experience from it
you know in the end i still feel
probably like
you know a lot of my stuff is spiritual
in nature and i probably just need to
have a relationship with a higher power
for myself
but i it could be better for sure i mean
i have one but it certainly could be
you know i just got one too a year ago
and
like or i've been trying to have one
within a like about over a year and like
accept a god or higher power or like
admit that i'm not in control
of all the things and that's kind of
like about the acceptance of like okay
i want to masturbate so i'm masturbating
i want to smoke weed okay i'm smoking
weed like the gentleness of like
you not you're not in control just do
just be
and and the higher power thing and raise
being raised as an atheist i don't know
how you were
oh you always raised his atheist really
yeah like really we weren't raised with
much
but we didn't i i just picked up things
from around the neighborhood you know
famous religion really yeah
oh yeah wow and like you know like if
you believe in god you're
probably dumber and you pro like those
are the things i kind of grew up with
like i
my parents would watch catch me watching
seventh heaven and they'd be like
what's going on like go memorize some
[ __ ] marilyn manson lyrics or
something you know like go
they they would be like disappointed i
would go to christian young life camp
because it was just a flirt with boys
and my friends and i like singing songs
i like singing sweet caroline
like those moments and they were just
like
you know it's crazy so now i feel really
weird being like telling my parents
my i was living with my parents over the
summer and i was so depressed
that i started praying because i just
had no hope left i was
when you mentioned ketamine i was like
tell me about it because i was so
depressed that i called neil brennan
being like
oh yeah i called gary goldman actually
being like i was about to call neil
but it didn't get that desperate but i
called gary goldman being like i'm going
to check myself in somewhere because i'm
[ __ ]
want to kill myself like i'm not going
to but yeah it's bad my brain is turned
against me and
and because my parents i'm living with
my parents they're like you hosted
kimmel last week
you have all these tour dates everyone's
like you have you're doing nothing
there's nothing that spurred this and
it's like i don't know what's going on
here
but i got caught praying one day because
i was trying to talk to a higher power
trying to just like
act as if there is oh yeah
like i am like a little mormon
like girl like i don't know how to
breathe so i get on my doesn't it feel
like something i feel like
when i put something like if i talk
inside of myself subconsciously to a
higher power
and i'm not saying your higher power
should be any specific religion i'm
saying anything like that
yeah but if you do that i feel like
something
hears me yeah it does and i feel like
it's
that i don't think that's a crazy thing
i haven't always felt like that in my
whole life
you know i but i feel it's like it does
and then it's nice because then life
every day isn't just my responsibility
it's not just up to you that's what i
love about it too because
you had somebody manipulated for
as soon as you finally accept it which
as someone who didn't believe in god and
like to accept that there's
someone looking out for me and that
always is with me even when i'm like
having a relapse or like always
you know i i kind of um my
my like biggest problem is like i quit
drinking but my biggest problem is like
eating disorder stuff and it's like
even when i start to do those behaviors
that i know lead to bet or i'm smoking
too much pot i'm just like
if i sit and acknowledge like whoever's
looking out for me this is the way it's
supposed to be
and just like then i the behavior
doesn't
it it doesn't affect you so much it
doesn't exist like i'm just like
okay someone's here with me like i got
nervous the other day but it's hard to
remember to do that
that's the thing of just being like hey
sometimes i talk to dead friends
and i feel like that helps me of like
hey can you not help me like
hey will you please get me this special
with hbo please get have them give me a
special i don't ask for things but i go
will you help me be okay no matter what
happens with this hbo special
and that's what i asked for and that
just whether or not it is true it just
[ __ ]
it helps yeah but it just feels like in
this
it feels like some to have some
connection to some other
so a higher source just feels like
i don't know it used to seem like it was
part of life so much more even if you go
back to native americans like their
spirit animal or the spirit you know
like
the fact that they would like pray to
the sun and the moon and like to the
water and like how it all works
and then here we are out here just like
you know
it's like these things we've created uh
you know all this technology and all
this stuff like it has so much more
power
you know it takes all our attention like
you're saying but it's not very
rewarding though i don't think it gives
us much of a reward but sometimes i'm on
instagram and i'm scrolling and i just
go you know what and i'll acknowledge it
i'll go
you've been scrolling a while and you're
not feeling good about this i just go
either you make a decision do you want
to keep doing this and if you do just do
it
you know don't have this right right
yeah don't also do the thing where you
feel bad about yourself yeah just do it
but acknowledge that you're doing it and
well i know we got to wrap things up but
um [ __ ] what was the thing that you were
saying about how long have we been going
praying so long
or 20 have we really it flies by
jc fam yeah just
ordered some lunch too actually um um
it's just
i want to know what you think about
sorry go on yeah but anyway i
i got really depressed but the thing
that same i got like diagnosed with
adhd and you have adhd as a as an adult
woman
and i never was diagnosed with it but i
went and got like you know
you're on the mat now yes and that is i
just
it's it's scary to like be depend on
something but i'm also on antidepressant
meds i just don't want to
have thoughts of killing myself i'm
tired of it i'm not it's it's like
what is that i wouldn't even like sit
and think like how am i gonna kill
myself i'd just be like sitting here
with you and then i would just like
think of and i just like
ah why is how many native americans
killed themselves you know they
i wonder i don't think many did you know
bow and arrow like this
i know yeah i wouldn't be the worst
they might have sacrificed themselves
but i think that's a total
different mental and spiritual animal
than just like oh and you're doing it
because your dad made you because you
have to sacrifice a virgin on the first
full moon or so you know what i mean
like yeah
i think you really so yeah suicide
though
is like yeah i think that's why you see
a lot of people trying to get back into
things that are just
more like you know i think it's one of
the nice things about
actually having uh getting a place
that's not in los angeles i just feel
there's a little bit more nature around
me it's like
i can go run a few times a week around
this lake radnor and it's like
it's just a couple miles you can worry
about where you're going running you
know
do you care if like the gang gang shows
up on your run
oh no i don't that's cool i see people
out there a lot
i see people when i'm running by yeah
yeah it's mostly a lot of uh
arabs like to go walk by the arabs use a
lot of parks they'll use a lot of parks
if you notice that
no middle eastern people love to use
parks they're smart parks like getting
out in nature it really does
it makes a huge difference it's a big
deal like i yeah i was just in
like the cayman islands and i was on two
and a half months dude and there's no
covet down there
i just stayed and then the show ended
and i stayed two more weeks because i'm
like i'm not coming back until
the states need me for something it was
awesome you're working on a show
yeah what kind of show is it um it's a i
can't say but it's i'm i'm host i don't
when is this coming out
tomorrow okay uh yeah i'm hosting a show
that i can't it's gonna be out this
summer but it's like
oh fun it was my it was the best thing
i've ever seen it was
yeah it was amazing after i like i
accepted a gig
that i truly accepted on based on
hearing the name of it and being like
yeah this is what i want to do like i
i'm loving my life right now and i feel
like
you are too like i feel like we're just
doing it was killing yourself a second
ago no no that was last summer
oh my god this was no i i got over my
depression
probably in the fall because i went and
got treated for it and i like on a dime
started treating my adhd and i have not
had one
suicidal ideation since then wow but
over the summer i was in a really dark
place and it could come back because
i've had those throughout my life do you
feel see one of my goals i would like to
get off of antidepressants that's one of
my goals which is one of the main
reasons why i tried the ketamine therapy
because it's had a lot of success with
getting people off antidepressants
i also want to do mushrooms and um lsd
to treat
yeah people are trying a lot of stuff
yeah i am i also want to go to burning
man
do you like sam harris i got his app uh
wake up
yeah yeah sam harris is the reason
i'm a a better person now than i was
this summer
he and many others there's a lot of good
stuff out there there's no free will
there's a lot of junk out there too
you know that's a tough thing you know
yes and he might be
like no i don't say he is i'm just
saying but there's a lot of junk
like i know that i fall for [ __ ] all the
time online you know
i didn't fall for that gwyneth paltrow
thing that everyone was
passing around with the vaginals or
whatever no she said there was some
headline the other day that was like
through the pandemic it's been really
tough one night i even had to eat bread
and everyone's going
oh my god i lost my grandfather but it
was fake she didn't say that
i'm not shocked yeah the see that that's
the thing she maybe said a comment but
they're like it's not
real well all nothing in the news none
of this is real but
sam harris is someone that has like his
app is so helpful
for if you're going through depression
or just existential crisis
but and the fact that there's no free
will has really helped me too
well i think uh what do you mean there's
no free will you mean
look into it if you read sammy harris's
book
free will the concept that you have any
control over
anything you do you want to talk about i
you're not in control of your own life
you're really not because it's too much
of a concept this might
if by any by the way this freaks anyone
out right now the idea that you're not
in control of
your life because the fact is you're not
that scares you you should probably not
trigger warning because some people with
like psychiatric dis like
illnesses can't handle this but
basically
uh free will doesn't the idea that you
are controlling anything you do the idea
that i'm like oh i'm gonna pet that rat
and i did it
okay yes i had the thought though of i'm
gonna pet that rat
did i choose that thought did i go i
could do anything right now and i'm
gonna go choose
no it just popped in my head so anything
that you can argue is a choice
is a thought that popped in your head
that you did not that you pulled out of
nowhere you didn't choose who your
parents were
you didn't choose that your heart's
beating much like those other things you
don't choose what you think
and everything you do is based on what
you think so if you're not choosing what
you think
there's it's either completely random or
it's uh determinism
which is like it's already laid out does
that make sense i mean it slightly makes
some sense i mean i think
it sounds it just sounds like more than
it sounds like a bigger thing that we'd
have to unpack
you know it sounds like a bigger that's
the basics and if anyone's interested
just i'm serious
look into because it really helped me
right this concept and i didn't know it
was a thing it's uh it's a short book
called free will by sam harris i could
see it taking a lot of pressure off of
people because then it's like
your the decisions and the choices you
make are not as
um they're not your fault they're not
gonna hamper yourself as much either
well nothing's your fault like when they
open up
this is a great example he gives in the
book when they open up a guy
that shoots up a [ __ ] mall or
something and they
they're how could he strip mall a strip
mall he shoots up a strip mall
they open up his brain they do an
autopsy and they find oh my god there is
a
giant tumor on his amygdala i'm just
making up i don't know if that
it it completely explains why this
otherwise normal man had this complete
shift
and and shot up the the mall actually he
would probably
get a different charge because of that
right because it wasn't his fault it was
his brain it was a tumor
right it's a it's not premeditated right
even if he planned it it wasn't as far
as the tumor
we have some sympathy for that guy in a
way that we don't have for a jeffrey
dahmer right or a
ted bundy who whether or not they opened
their brain and found something
we just go that guy plans these things
he's a crazy person
when really ted bundy didn't want to be
born with
he didn't choose the brain that made him
a serial killer and you go
well if i were ted bunny i wouldn't have
done that yes you would have
because everyone does exactly what
they're going to do and there's no
it gives you an immense empathy and i'm
not saying i forgive
child molesters or murderers or someone
who could like hurt my family i would be
furious because that's just human nature
but i
understand that when i think of child
monsters i kind of
i'm so angry at what they do and
disgusted by it but there's a part of me
that's like
no one would choose to be born with a
brain oh yeah i think some of that
there's a lot of sympathy
they need to like get help and do what
they need to get help but there's a lot
of that i go
they didn't choose that and people have
a hard time that's a really
weird concept but if you break it down
everything is something that's weird in
your brain so whether it's a tumor or
just your brain's weird and we can't
really see what's weird
it's still not your fault it's your
brain well i think some of that will be
interesting as we learn you know just as
we evolve more and learn more and we
start to
see like um you know empathy
is such a big thing you know and just
how much uh are you good with it
i think i'm pretty good with that
honestly a lot of times because i've
always felt that way the way you're
talking about
like even my friends that have gotten
trouble for sex stuff like our friends
that have gotten trouble like
i usually always think like what
happened to him you know like how did it
start like
yeah that's great but i mean it still
doesn't take away also though
also though you live in an environment
in a society and society is shaped where
people have to have punishments
sometimes and and and things that happen
and sometimes some people need to go
back into the broth man i get it
and i understand that we want to punish
people and say like
you you i you hurt my friend i'm gonna
hurt you eye for an eye but really the
reason we put these people away is
because
they harm society and it's not it's not
an example
to people to not do that but it's it's
it's not so much retribution because we
should just be like wow that sucks that
he's a serial killer and his brain is
like that
and we put them away but we put them
away as an example of not what to do
to not to not do what they do for people
and we want them
out there and we want to protect people
yeah you gotta go
huh no i'm gonna i'm gonna you're gonna
eat lunch yeah just real fast
but uh or not but i'm just gonna to have
someone but i love that
yeah i've got something tenders um no
you don't like them oh you can't eat
them huh it's all that i can i won't
okay oh these are for me too oh yeah
no thank you i i'm not trying to be
people hate vegans but um yeah
no way yeah i so can you give if you
what if you do a bj can you do a
finisher yeah it's not harming an animal
i mean a couple of my early ones my
first one
might have harmed a fellow human uh
because i didn't know what to do with my
teeth but um
no calm is like that's fine you can
see most people call it seed most people
call calm seed
or semen i don't go give me your i want
your
seed but i i feel like calm is the is
the one
really yeah i call it [ __ ] when you're in
bed with a girl and you say i'm gonna
can you take my can you ingest my seed
what do you say to her i'm going to
exceed
i'm going to plant i'm going to harvest
maybe um sorry i say calm no i'll keep
it going
so uh yeah i don't eat i don't need
animals because i love animals
now what if you met an animal and he's
violent he's killing other animals stuff
like that yeah i can kill him
but he's a jeffrey dahmer of animals
still we have to kill him because he's
killing other animals he's
his sacrifice will be less than how much
harm he could put in the world see
that's one of the things overall
sometimes you have to do things just for
the greater good
that's what um putting people in jail is
fours but like
well do you believe in the death penalty
then no i mean by
buy these by this logic no because but
i i believe in it because if i got that
life sentence i would
i would really want to be put to death
oh please
i believe in it just like as a i'm i'm
advocating for the prisoners to like
have that option
like just i don't even care if their
machine your chair's not working let's
just do a uh
shoot me mm-hmm like i would rather i
like when the world ends and the wave
comes i just want to have a i want to
have a gun just so i can like kill
myself before
some natural disaster obviously it's a
better way to go than
hopefully i think some prisoners will
wise up and they will get the
option to have the death penalty yeah
and some of them would choose
people are so scared of death it would
be better to go back into the
[Music]
amoeba or the the sphere that that yeah
and have a new shot at a retro at a
retribution of existence
that it would be here and piddle around
like writing letters to the girls
yeah and just be a some because then
you're just part of some um
documentary that some creep is going to
make because
they want to make money off the people i
watch those youtube videos of like them
interviewing sociopaths i love
sociopaths and psychopaths
i just what's a murder you could do and
be honest with me okay um bill cosby
you could do rape i could um probably
strangle him
oh you could kill him you mean yeah i'll
tell you what's a murder you could
commit
oh maybe i shouldn't have said that then
but i would love to just see his eyes
pop out even more as i
slowly choke the life out of him for
being probably a murderer and
the most prolific serial rapist that any
of us have ever known
um a murder i could do a gun
you know like if there was a burglar or
something like i could stab someone i
could
um i could do anything in self defense i
wouldn't like my dad always says if a
guy you're in a car with a guy
and you uh he's taking you an
undisclosed location
you're gonna get murdered right if a guy
grabs you and shoves you in a car and
you're screaming
don't don't try to like hang out for the
car ride wherever you're going
you're gonna get murdered you gotta jump
out so just try to wreck the car even if
you're on a highway but the best thing
to do if you can is like gouge their
eyes and that would be hard for me to do
just to feel
but actually i feel great to someone
like that is about to rape and murder
you just go
and like dig as far as you can and you
have to do it and then the car will flip
but you have a better chance of
surviving that then
he's not going to take you to go do a
podcast you know like
you're gonna it's gonna be bad see
that's one thing i think that's tough
for a lot of women is you have that
that chance out there of getting
sexually assaulted you have the chance
to get like if somebody picks me up
they just are going to want to either
spend time with me or give me a ride
that's what i was thinking about the run
but hold on theo this brings us
to one of the one of the moments i'll
never forget about you
that i had on the street in front of the
improv on melrose do you remember
you were coming back from your car i was
leaving the melrose improv it was
probably like 2017.
and i was on a jog no you were you were
um coming back you went like you were
maybe coming wait hold on
i was walking that way you were yeah you
were coming back to the improv
from your car maybe going to get
something or maybe you were coming for
the first time i go hi
theo and i see you and i passed you on
the sidewalk we're kind of further down
i remember this west from melrose you'll
remember it because you go
i go hey it's kind of in like a couple
blocks more where the comics park
it's see it's scary it's coming it's
seedy you know
and so i do remember this and i was
walking it was in a part that's a little
scary
and i go hey and then you bet you pass
and you go don't get raped
and i go yeah thanks
i was just like [ __ ] you because i was
annoyed because it's like if you
think if that is sincere of like hey be
careful
yeah just walk me to my car you know
where i'm going yeah and then
also like it's up to me whether or not i
get raped is the other kind of it's a
funny thing to say because it's like
that's a big reach you know what i'm
saying but but just being like don't get
it's just
saying something flippant about a thing
that i actually fear every time i leave
there
right but you didn't know that and so it
was me going like i go
thanks and i'm in my car just like oh
god that was not a fun run right i
didn't care i i really did get to a
place of like he doesn't know
he doesn't know the experience of being
a woman and like didn't think about it
it was just
we were like you were like uh we were
awkward almost you were just like huh
and just like said something
we all do that so i forgive you but then
you texted me right after it we're like
hey i'm really sorry that felt so weird
and that wasn't cool to say and i should
have walked you you like
said all the nice things in the text
like right after and that always meant a
lot to me
but and i could tell that you were like
but yeah just walk in my car next time
yeah do you walk girls to cars yeah i'll
walk girls to cars i make sure they get
in the vehicles
get girls ubers you know yeah i think i
do all that kind of stuff
i don't know why i said it maybe i
thought that it was just a good maybe
this the environment was right for the
jokes
no it is because also i'm a comic and
that's a funny joke
well that's a tough thing too when
you're talking with comics it's like and
it's like that's the
thing that sucks about the world it
sucks that you couldn't make a race joke
a few minutes ago without everybody
thinking you're a [ __ ] racist yeah
like you just have to and you kind of
can it's like you don't have to be
but i might catch someone in a
vulnerable state like you caught me in a
vulnerable state where i was already
thinking about being raped and i might
say a race joke and it catches someone
who's watching who is black and was
discriminating against today
all day today they didn't get something
because they are black that
it's just they know it and then they
hear me say a racial joke and it just
makes them go like
god another [ __ ] thing like
right it can catch someone in the wrong
time i agree but then we've gotten to
this space in the world where it's like
around that but i also i want a career
right and i want to be able to say
things
because we have to do things that's for
the common good like it's gotten to this
point where it's like
you're never going to make everybody on
twitter happy everybody has a voice now
it's impossible to make everyone happy
and so
you have to be able to take some risks
in every in every facet of life
you know because don't you know that
like you have to do things with the
common good it's like
99.5 percent of people would just laugh
at the joke
yes and then there's that and is that
one person that's had a tough day yes
they've had a tough day
but we're also starting to raise people
to think that just because they've had
and speaking of that had a bad day that
i'm having but
do you like this or no no i don't you
can't have it i can't i can't have any
of it and i don't really
i'm not admitted i love birds and so
eating chickens to me seems crazy
but if a man eats it was that you deter
you from being around that man i i
really like a guy to maybe wrap his head
around like
understanding because i don't not eat
chicken because it's not good that's
[ __ ] delicious everything you're
eating
is something that i enjoyed for years of
my life and i'm i do miss
yeah but i don't do things that
sometimes that i want to do because it's
right
like i don't murder people that i want
to murder i don't hit my friend
i don't hit my mom sometimes when i want
to hit her because it's not good for the
greater
for the world and eating chickens and
eating chicken well you have to be able
to eat something
at a certain point what's next and you
can't have plant like you're not getting
a salad as feeling the thing is so
stupid the what's next i understand it
but like
when people go plants oh feelings okay
when when that's proven when plants
are like i can see the humanity in a
plant's eyes and i can see
i can see a pig and i see my dog at a
pig it's not a hard thing to do right i
understand people can separate fish
and squids even though my octopus
teachers should ruin that for everyone
they can kind of go okay those things
are like insects they're lobsters
they're like roaches
but when you eat a pig and a chicken if
you've ever had i had a parakeet says
child
as a child they were the best that are
beautiful they were the best
pets i've ever had i loved that bird
more than i've loved dogs and i love
dogs but i had more of a connection that
more of a personality was smarter than
my dogs i i'm more in kiwi and then one
day i was like
chickens are [ __ ] kiwi like he that
parakeet and chickens
chickens might be even smarter than me i
don't know yeah but does it matter if
something's dumb though because
something's dumb doesn't mean
it means it should be killed we don't do
that to humans but mother nature kills
us sometimes
sure and uses us to go back into the
earth go hunt all you want just don't
make animals suffer up until you kill
them i don't care
guys i'm like [ __ ] yeah it's not the
killing put them out of their goddamn
misery much like
the jail thing let the death penalty is
great in a cow's life because
the cow's existence up until the death
penalty is what i'm bothered by
right and you can't guarantee that these
animals are treated well so many are up
until they're slaughtered but
because you can't guarantee i just you
know sometimes i look at eggs and i go
i'll buy the most expensive ones because
these are probably the ones that are
treated right but it's just a picture of
a woman like
holding a chicken and you're like oh
that woman picked these eggs okay i'm
gonna it's like no that's the label
right i don't know unless my sister had
chickens and i definitely ate those
um chickens and look at the thing about
it is man i think if you
i wish we knew here's what i wish i wish
we could get inside the brain of a
chicken and know if they mined or not
they definitely mind they definitely
any of course i'm not saying they don't
i'm just saying i wish we had
and i think down the line we will have
that ability yeah we're all gonna look
so stupid and i'm not saying that i'm
perfect and that everyone needs to go
vegan but
to my mom won't watch the octopus
teacher this thing that humanizes
octopuses and
like not humanizes but like makes them
like you realize like they have emotions
and this person like
it really [ __ ] you up apparently if you
watch this and my mom loves calamari so
much that she won't watch it she goes
i feel like if i watch that i won't eat
it anymore i'm like then why
so you're living ignorantly so that you
can protect yourself because you like
[ __ ] but then it's always gonna be
like that this so but then it's just
gonna become whoever has
owns the media is just gonna be able to
influence and then they create the
products that they want us to buy then
you know
but like at least those products
hopefully vegans are not doing
anything wrong except wanting animals i
have nothing wrong with it be happy
yeah and that's people people do have a
lot i mean people are skipping this part
oh really
people hate vegans the i used vegans i
used to have like a bit about it in my
act and i
dated a vegan and i was called
somebody's a vegan maybe but don't make
me have to be a vegan if you're a vegan
no i'm not making you i'm just kind of
trying to say the same things that
when i wasn't a vegan kind of made me
see the other side and actually embrace
it and really love it and i'm just
sharing with you my experience of
realizing that
animals want to live just like we do and
pigs are terrified from the second
they're born
cows and pigs most of them i know not
all get plucked from the mom they're
scared
the whole time they're shaking then
they're forced they never have a single
charlotte
moment of no it's not because
charlotte's web is
that's a good experience at least that
pig knew some like
like warmth these animals never know
warmth a pet
never any not one minute of it from the
time they're plucked from their mom
until they're put loaded on trucks
they're they're
stuck in pens they're just they're just
made to get fat that there's no one
that's caring about their needs so this
animal that is capable of
deep deep feelings like your dog never
sees in its however long it lives life
it never sees a shroud of of kindness to
it and then it's slaughtered
how can you how can you do that well
[ __ ] but i i i
look at those i'm not doing it i i i'm
not doing that i'm having some raising
canes i'm enjoying it
i mean you can take this out because eat
what you want i really i don't care i'm
just saying what i learned that that's
why i can't even
mean anymore and i [ __ ] hate it
because i miss [ __ ] feta cheese
i miss frozen so is part of it that you
just miss those things and you want to
have them and so you're angry at other
people
i mean that's the classic hack [ __ ]
joke they're angry because they're weak
because of protein i didn't say that i'm
angry because i just don't understand
why people who love dogs and i know like
you know dedicate their lives to saving
dogs can
eat pigs i just don't get it can eat
pigs that they know
have never seen if you if one minute of
what that pig that you're eating is life
or that chicken that you're eating life
happened to your like i don't know if
you have a you don't have a dog you've
never had i don't have a dog i've
considered getting a dog i'm thinking
about maybe getting a welsh terrier or
something can you bring that up next
yeah so if if
for people listening at home if a minute
of the pain that
uh a chicken that you're eating or a pig
that you're eating is life and i know
it's not your fault you didn't put them
in that situation you're just trying to
eat food i get it
look at that but if you're if you're a
little welsh terrier that you get
something that you're gonna love
more than you ever even thought possible
loving a dog because that's what happens
if you had if someone inflicted that
kind of life for 30 seconds onto a dog
that a chicken and a pig experienced
their entire life for 30 seconds
you would want to [ __ ] murder you
would you would have that person charged
with cruelty they kept them in a box for
that dog that it wasn't able to run its
legs were
scabbed up it had sores in its eyes like
the things that happened to these
animals
if we had a little bit of it for our
precious pets we would never tolerate it
yet when we see
when we can't see the footage and we
don't want to see it so i just
i didn't do it and it's that kind of
thing and by the way i
definitely contribute to horrific
injustices
to humans yeah there's tons it will
never end i mean at a certain point
i just chose one and that's my one cool
yeah yeah i think
um but yeah i still buy from amazon so i
just want to be clear
yeah i mean i'm still part of the
problem i mean it's crazy because like
there's also
countries where they eat dog and they
eat like things that are major i kind of
like that they do i like that they go
you know what
we count we're gonna [ __ ] eat dog i
wish we would start eating dog because
it would make people wake up to the fact
that
why isn't this okay i would have some
dog you should you know what i
i honestly i don't want that to happen
but i do think that people need to wake
the [ __ ] up
and realize that when you when we go to
china to
like say don't have this yulin meat dog
meat festival how could they eat dogs
but i think there used to be
how you would never [ __ ] ever eat a
hamburger nicky i think there used to be
times where there was like a connection
between animals and
humans and nature and so if they took
something's life because they needed to
survive
and that's what they did the cow lived
in in a natural environment
or if it was formed it was treated nice
and had a good life i've always said we
should
i i more value it when someone hunts
with a knife
when people go what about when rogan
launches elk i'm like do it
those elk lived a good life they just
like caught a [ __ ]
stray bullet like you things happen but
at least they [ __ ]
[ __ ] a lot and ate a lot and jumped
over creeks and like
had some adventures in their life that
animals are supposed to
so maybe you want more you want animals
to have
have an adventure outward-bound
experience eat we take these animals
and give them a week solution in the
wild yeah now i love that you want ymca
camp
for these animals while they grow up
before and that's what a lot of
like one more thing there's a thing
called in the vegan community that i
would never do called bearing witness
and peta does it a lot where they meet
up with these slaughter trucks as
they're coming in
the pigs are coming to slaughterhouse
they're packed into these things
and you can just see their snouts
through these little cages and they're
dying of thirst they're just they're
basically dead because
if they were dead who cares so when pigs
are when you
if i finish the soda and i was just
talking to you i would just start
crinkling the can because i know it's
trash it's going in the trash i'm not
saving this i'm not trying to make this
right right you're not gonna yeah you're
not gonna give them the best last meal
it's not like a prison system
yeah a pig so it's that's headed to
slaughter i'm gonna
you just treat it like [ __ ] so these
pigs are in the worst conditions headed
to slaughter
and these people go and just it's called
bearing witness because
just to see just to honor a pig's life
and go like i see you
and i knew you were an animal that
deserved more and i'm really sorry and
just to be there and
like they hope they hold a vigil because
it's set and they they feed water to
these thirsty pigs to the thing
and that to me is like i could never do
that i can't even look at
footage i just read stuff and no because
it but
that's the kind of thing that i hear and
i just go
that's pretty much an outward bound
experience of like i'm going to show you
a pet the one gentleness you'll get your
whole life because you've been kicked
and prodded
and living in [ __ ] and eating bad stuff
that doesn't even taste good that's just
going to make you fat
i mean it's just so sad i mean i think
some of it is not
people's fault though some of it is just
the way that
society has evolved and also if you have
to if you have to feed a family like
there was no i there's no opportunities
for a lot of people to go do all
types of certain things like that's what
i'm saying you don't have to go all
vegan just one
if you can do one meal where you eat
sometimes you don't have a choice like
that is a
parent that's trying to take care of
their kids but there are plant-based
options at burger king now like there's
ways around it that tastes good i'm
serious i'm i i know that vegan stuff is
expensive and i can say that
it's elitist of me to be able to like
just go switch to plant-based get
meals delivered to your doorstep but
there's really affordable options now
and that's
really old rhetoric of being like it's
too expensive there's
there's way but i'm just saying some
people's lifestyles it's not an
option in their lifestyle i'm not
telling if if that resonates with
everyone
you want to do it then you can do it all
i do is i have to spread the message
because it's [ __ ] like this that got me
to adopt it and so i know i might sound
like a jehovah's witness right now and
i'm like i have to spread the lord's
message
that's what i feel in my heart for
animals is my job and
like i said i am letting severe
injustices of human injustices happen
and i don't speak up for it because i
this is just my cause i pick and i'm
drawn to it
and i it works i've made a lot of people
go vegan and the only reason i went
vegan is because vegans would shut the
[ __ ]
up and so i know it works they were
annoying as [ __ ]
yeah and they finally got to me so i
have to be annoying as [ __ ] there's no
other way to do it
well sometimes things got to be said um
you have a new tour that's coming right
yeah one night only no
yeah one night with nikki glazier one
night
it's um it's like because it's all about
sex no it's
it's going to be um amazing i'm so
excited
because dude my theater tour last time
got stopped in the middle you were doing
theaters for a while right
yeah i just finished my tour when covet
started your first one
yeah like your first theater tour yeah
what was it was it great
yeah it was cool it was hard i i had
been already doing clubs like
like in a row for like a year and a half
i was just exhausted by the end i was
exhausted that was what i felt on mine
last year
it was just doing clubs up until the
first theatre tour date and then all of
a sudden it's a theater and people are
paying more money
the pressure's on and i did cool stuff
like i finished with a dance
andrew uh colin my co-host on nicki
laser podcast and uh my best friend and
roommate and then my other best friend
anja marina like
she opened with music like i had a band
open and i brought my friends on the
road it was so fun and then cove it
happened it all shut down right and then
and i've in covid i've learned how to
play guitar i might like
i'm going to sing a song with my friend
anya and like i might do like
private concerts before my shows like at
cafes in town where i just do taylor
swift like sing-alongs and i'm not even
joking you like it's
i'm bad at guitar but i like singing
taylor swift with other swifties
okay fans so i might start doing that
but like the the show itself and my dad
and i sang over the summer
oh yeah i remember seeing that i did a
version of lady gaga and bradley
cooper's um
uh that you know shallow yeah but we
rewrote it about me living at home with
my parents and it was
really [ __ ] funny it was all about
you know i've gotta leave i've gotta go
and like hearing my parents [ __ ] through
the wall but it was like
and it sounds like a dumb it was really
good
i went to voice lessons and like learned
how to sing like gaga and
it was [ __ ] singing is [ __ ] funny
my dad's an amazing musician
are you a good singer or not i i can be
but i quit singing lessons and i i smoke
a lot of pot now but
apparently my singing teacher's like do
whatever i'll work with it like rock and
roll artists
smoke so they smoked cigarettes all the
time like you smoked pot
oh yeah i think everybody has some
people thousand times advice that they
take out with them
yeah and so i um i love singing and this
but the stand-up show is not gonna be
singing it's gonna be me like
roasting like doing rose stuff talking
about rose because people love that and
they expect that from me now
is there you know i'm like is it a mixed
bag though there could be singing there
could be special guests it could be
whatever there's gonna be like
i'm gonna i i really am excited about
like the whole thing like it's just
it's it's never gonna be boring you're
never gonna be watching something and
going like oh my god i don't wanna watch
nikki's friend like play music it's
gonna be like
this is [ __ ] really [ __ ] good like
my friend anya marine is like a legend
i have friends that are talented that
wanna work and i can
make them money this way it's so nice
and then i get to bring my dad who's
[ __ ] 66 he's been playing in bars and
at nursing homes during covid like
outside their windows and what his name
is jim
his name is ej glazer and he's a he's
such a good musician he's always wanted
me to sing and play guitar and when i
moved back home over quarantine
this thing that my dad always wanted me
to do and i was like i'm not good at it
i'm not as good as your dad
like like billy elliot yeah like what
does a j stand for ernest james
uh edward uh john edward johnson yeah
yeah he's very cool in any way so we uh
so i'm gonna
sing with him and then i might and then
i'm gonna have special guests like i
just i'm gonna fly my friends out that's
my new life it's just like
dude i love it i love the fact you were
able to kind of like get into st louis
yeah and i know you have the mtv uh
you're gonna be honest i was just saying
that because i'm hosting them this week
i'm like out
here and instead of getting a hotel and
just being like i usually come out and
do my stuff and then
hang with my other friends i was like in
case my ally friends are busy or like
whatever i'm just gonna bring my friends
with me and so i got a house in the
hills
airbnb and like i brought all my friends
like who i brought here today it's like
so these things that i used to go like
i'm hosting this award show and it's
like
it's me and my spray tan and like i'm
alone and like
i don't even know what thing i'm gonna
say and i'm like freaking out it's like
i constantly have friends around that
are like
you're fine like let's play guitar for a
second oh my god let's like talk about
this funny thing
i saw like it's just it's so great to be
in this position
and to like be able to just like today
just doing work that like
you like and getting comfortable i think
getting to a place in your life where
you're comfortable to exist as you
change yes that's one thing i think i
hear a lot from you even just in this
conversation is just
getting to a place in your life where
you feel comfortable
um like i usually like before we started
i was like i want to check the shot to
make sure like
should i wear this shirt am i looking
like i'm like sexy
because i'm always scared that someone's
gonna go she's trying to look hot
when really like of course i am i'm
[ __ ] single this is like a platform
to like get people's att why wouldn't i
look hot like it's like married
and even married so but the thing is i
um if i don't if i see this later and i
go because there's a lot of times i see
stuff of me and any girl and lots of
guys watching would relate
where you just go like i am disgust like
i have really low self-esteem when it
comes to my looks like oh yeah
it started really early and it's just
there but now over this past year i'm
just like
i don't know what happened dude like i
just don't care i like when i see myself
looking
really [ __ ] ugly and like dry skin
and i look like old like i'm like
i look like sometimes i see my face i'm
like [ __ ] you're old and i am i'm 36
like sometimes i'm like you're
you look like 42. that's okay i just had
a [ __ ] dry day yeah i need to
moisturize more like
and i am gonna who cares and in the way
that i
like i feel like anyone who likes me is
still gonna like me if i look like [ __ ]
the people i love when they start
looking like [ __ ]
i i'm on board it's okay you didn't let
me down
you're allowed to look like [ __ ] someday
if you want to even though you won't
yeah but i love her so much i would i
don't care
and so now i like myself and now when i
look like gross i just go like
oh boy you look at a little yeah a
little husky today
and those pants were a mistake it's like
little christmas people just like
laugh i laugh at like i used to be
really embarrassed at how messy i was
like my car i don't want people i have
to like
clean my car if a boy is gonna get in
now i'm just like if this guy is someone
you know
yeah look at look at my trash this is
not in here hold this
apple bottle because i have lacroix
hands in the passenger seat
maybe that's not so funny yeah i could
relate to a lot of that i don't care
anymore how the reflection of this year
environment
i don't want to present any way i'm not
because if you get to be authentic
across the board and really are like i
am who i am and that's okay
then you don't have to ever think i
literally don't have to
because the thing i realize is about
comedy and you tap into it big time
because
this is the thing i notice about you is
you just talk and it's funny like
i know you're aware of what you say is
funny but you talk in a way that you
almost act like you don't know
but i also think that you can't you're
in a position now that you know
that your fans get you and you know that
you're funny
that you can show up and you don't
really have to prepare you can just
start talking
and it's gonna be good enough like maybe
prepare a little bit but
i could get on stage and talk about
[ __ ] anything and be entertaining at
this point because i've done it that
long
and within that is like this freedom to
be people are at ease audiences want to
watch you comfortable if i'm comfortable
and not worried about what you think
they lap it up because and we feel good
then too i notice if i'm having
fun man if i'm in a good place then yeah
that shows you zenith being honest
if i'm not in a good place i'll just be
like man i am [ __ ] depressed today
or if i'm too sometimes i go on stage
i'm too high my new thing is i'm just
gonna be like guys i'm really high
because the audience just wants in
yeah they went in on what's going they
sent something weird what is it oh she's
high
yeah the wheat i took one i thought i
wanted one hit i took two i got greedy
now we're in a weird place now i've
broken this weirdness that i in my head
go
thick you shouldn't have smoked weed
before the set you're such a bad
comedian now what's your next joke
what's the next joke
you shouldn't have done that's a word
and now i just go i'm high everyone and
now it's like
okay no more secrets i've got like let's
just be honest
yeah and i think that's what comedy is
just being honest let's be honest and so
as long as you just
talk honestly it's going to be funny and
good and people are going to like it
yeah i think that's a that's a i think
that's one thing i'm trying to tap into
a little bit more getting into some of
this next tour
um one of the things i want to work on
more in the coming months i can't wait
to see
your we we never get to watch anymore
but it's like
i really i really dig your stuff and
it's i'm a true fan and i it's i've met
you
not knowing what your comedy was like at
all and had but you have to do this
before but for the past
many many years you've been one of my my
faves and someone that i'm just like
i always watch your [ __ ] thank you
you've always said
you've always said some really nice
stuff to me and i appreciate that every
time i'm just like
same here when i see you [ __ ] am i doing
up there i need to like
just start telling the truth or the
weird or the wackiest way to say it or
just like
saying when you say limousine of
rats right okay how did that occur to
you i want to know how that joke popped
in your brain because i'm not kidding
you that was the funniest thing i've
heard in a while
i don't know i think just something long
that's it and then we're talking about
an animal and
you just pulled long and then we had
that ferret and so then i just thought
of those things
that's so simple it's like the first
thing that entered in your mind
like sometimes i overthink things but
sometimes i just gotta go
it's a long rat what's long boom easy
limousine limousine i don't make them
anymore so they're so messed up and look
at that
yeah it's like a water slide of p yes
there you go it's uh um i mean this joe
could go that's a
you know one of it looks honestly looks
like one of the penises and the porn
that i watched quite often oh damn okay
i watched some bigs
my porn consumption is just some of this
stuff another podcast
out there yeah i mean i feel really bad
for guys
out there based on porn i really do
because to even
you're right you do but our vaginas are
different in comparison too so we're
also feeling the same kind of insecurity
and i just want to let guys out there
with small dicks know like
literally i don't you can just use a
dildo to [ __ ] me it and then just like
yeah long as you're cheering me on long
as you're there supporting long as
you're not on your phone the whole time
sex i've had is with a guy with a penis
yeah using a dildo hey man all right
stop just saying that look i think that
covers everything
uh one night with nikki glazer right yes
tickets on sale nikki well some places
are too nice and so
but it's a uh nikki glazer.com
tour for tickets they're on sale now and
they're i'm
pretty happy people are turning out but
people really like my podcast yeah
like i never promote podcast because i'm
always like what am i doing but i love
the way you're doing it at home now
you're in your house every day
you like find out about i can't help but
like share gossip about my life you
catch up on like stories going on
it's very interactive with fans it's
it's it was inspired by watching people
like you
and how you do it and just are yourself
so if you like this show and you liked
my appearance and you made it to the end
definitely subscribe to the nikki laser
broadcast and then unsubscribe if you
don't like it i don't care
yeah but just subscribe yeah give it
away why don't we go
jump in you don't have to listen to old
episodes just jump on in yeah
anytime yeah you don't have to start
from the beginning no with andrew conlon
and uh colin yep nikki thank you so much
for being here today thank you theo
always fun
yeah and thank you raising kings for my
launch and yes thank you
maybe they'll have a vegan option in the
future i think they should if they did i
would be so
i would be so cool with that they have
that yeah i don't know
we got to actually the the guy who
started raising canes is from louisiana
he's coming on the podcast next
no i know that that's like everyone's
favorite fried chicken
and so uh yeah that's pretty cool that
you're having that guy good good on him
it'd be interesting just to hear how it
all happened you know
i mean for so much i'll probably skip it
but yeah
i'm just kidding i'm interested i
support people in the
i get it that was the best ending ever
nicky glazer ladies and gentlemen thank
you so much for coming in
[Music]
oh but when i reach that ground i'll
share this
[Music]
that parking
i'll sit and tell you my story
[Music]
just
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway train with a heavy load of
my
hands
and these wells that i've been riding on
[Music]
there